we tend to be told in algebra class that
if we have a line our line will have a
constant rate of change of Y with
respect to X or another way of thinking
about that a line will have a constant
inclination or that our line will have a
constant slope and our slope is
literally defined as your change in Y
this triangle is the Greek letter Delta
it's a shorthand for change in it means
change in Y Delta Y means change in Y
over change in X and if you're dealing
with a line this right over here is
constant constant for a line what I want
to do in this video is to actually prove
that using similar triangles from
geometry so let's think about two two
sets of two points so let's say that's a
point then we do in a different color
let me start at this point and let me
end up at that point so what is our
change in X between these two points so
this points X value is right over here
this points X value is right over here
so our change in X our change in X is
going to be that right over there and
what's our change in Y well this point
to Y value is right over here this
points Y value is right over here so
this height or this height is our change
in Y so that is our change in Y now
let's look at two other points let's say
I have this point and this point right
over here and let's do the same exercise
what's the change in X well let's see if
we're going this Y this points X values
here this points X values here so if we
start here and we go this far this would
be this would be the change in X between
this point and this point and this and
this is going to be the change let me do
that same green color so this is going
to be the change in X between those two
points and our change in Y well this Y
value is here this Y value is up here so
our change in Y is going to be that
right over here
so what I need to show I'm just picking
two arbitrary points I need to show that
the ratio of this change in Y to this
change of X is going to be the same as
the ratio of this change in Y to this
change of X or the ratio of this purple
side to this green side is going to be
the same as the ratio of this purple
side to this green side remember I'm
just picking two sets of arbitrary
points here and the way that I will show
it is through similarity if I can show
that this triangle is similar to this
triangle then we are all set up and just
as a reminder of what similarity is two
triangles are similar and there's
multiple ways of thinking about it
so you're similar if and only if all
corresponding or I should say all three
angles are the same or are congruent so
all three and let me be carefully they
don't have to be the same exact exact
angle the corresponding angles have to
be the same so corresponding so core
this corresponding always spell it
corresponding corresponding angles
angles are going to be equal or we could
say they are congruent so for example if
I have this triangle right over here and
this is 30 this is 60 and this is 90 and
then I have this triangle right over
here I'll try to draw it so this
triangle where this is 30 degrees this
is 60 degrees and this is 90 degrees
even though their side lengths are
different these are going to be similar
triangles or essentially scaled up
versions of each other all the
corresponding angles 60 is corresponds
to this 60 30 corresponds to this 30 and
90 corresponds to this one so these two
triangles are similar and what's neat
about similar triangles if you can
establish that two triangles are similar
then the ratio between corresponding
size is going to be the same so if these
two are similar then the ratio of this
side to this side is going to be the
same as the ratio of this let me do that
pink color
of this side of this side to this side
and so you can see why that will be
useful in proving that the slope is
constant here because all we have to do
is look if these two triangles are
similar then the ratio between
corresponding sides is always going to
be the same we've picked two arbitrary
sets of points then this would be true
really for any two arbitrary sets of
points across the line would be true for
the entire line so let's try to prove
similarity so the first thing we know is
that both of these are right triangles
these green lines are perfectly
horizontal these purple lines are purple
lines literally go along the exit or go
in the horizontal direction the purple
lines go in the vertical direction so
let me make sure that we mark that so we
know that these are both right-angles so
we have one corresponding angle that is
congruent now we have to show that the
other ones are and we can show that the
other ones are using our knowledge of
parallel lines and transversals let's
look at these two green lines so and
I'll continue them these are line
segments but if we view them as lines
and we just continue them on and on and
on so let me do that just like here so
this line is clearly parallel to that
one they essentially are perfectly
horizontal and now you can view our
orange line as a transversal and if you
view it as a transversal then you know
that this angle corresponds to this
angle and we know from transversals of
parallel lines that corresponding angles
are congruent so this angle is going to
be congruent to that angle right over
there now we make a very similar
argument for this angle but now we use
the two vertical lines we know that this
segment we could continue it as a line
so we could continue it if we want it as
a line so just like that a vertical line
and we can continue this one as a
vertical line we know that these are
both vertical they're just measuring
they're exactly in the Y direction in
the vertical direction so this line this
line is parallel to this line right over
here once again our orange line is a
transversal is a transversal of it and
this angle corresponds to this angle
right over here and there we have it
they're congruent corresponding angles
the transversal of two parallel lines
are congruent we learn
that in geometry class and there you
have it all of the corresponding this
angle is congruent to this angle this
angle is congruent to that angle and
then both of these are 90 degrees so
both of these are similar triangles so
both of these are similar so let me
write that down so we know that these
are both similar similar similar
triangles and now we can use the common
ratio of both sides so for example if we
called if we call this side length a and
we said that this has the side has
length B and we said this side has
length C and this side has length D we
know for a fact that the ratio because
these are similar triangles the ratio
between corresponding sides the ratio of
A to B the ratio of A to B is going to
be equal to the ratio of C to D is equal
to the ratio of C to D and so and that
ratio is literally the definition of
slope your change in Y over your change
in X and this is constant because any
sum any triangle that you generate this
right triangles that you generate
between these two points we've just
shown that they are going to be similar
and if they are similar than the ratio
of this vertical line the length of this
vertical line segment to this horizontal
line segment is constant that is the
definition of slope so the slope is
constant for a line